Next, we'll design a blueprint and event trigger within our sequence.
This will serve as the logic to handle our player input event during gameplay.
So let's jump back over to our project, and the first step that we need to do is
to create our new blueprint actor.
So I'm going to go down to our content drawer, and in our sequence 20500, under
BP, you'll see that we already have the BP sequence manager.
This is what we're going to create, but I'm going to go ahead and just walk you
through the steps of how we create this.
So I'm just going to right click, and I'm going to do blueprint class, and we're
going to select our actor, and we'll give it a name like BP, and we can do
underscore SEQ MGR for sequence manager.
Go ahead and just double click to open this.
Now, what we're going to do with this particular blueprint actor is it's
essentially just going to act as a in-between to pass commands to and from
our sequence and the player.
So it's sort of like a phone operator.
So what we want to do within this blueprint is I'll go ahead and go on
this left hand side, and underneath our event dispatchers, we're going to click
the plus, and this is where we're going to create something called the
pause dispatcher.
Go ahead and hit compile and save.
And essentially what we're going to do with this pause dispatcher, again, this
is going to be our container to handle inputs or commands from our
sequence to the player and to do things.
That's it.
That's all we need.
We go ahead and close this.
And we'll go back down to our content drawer, and I'm going to
just drag this into our world.
I'll just kind of move it up where we can see it.
So now we have our BP sequence manager.
Now, just as a quick note that if you were building this for a future
project and you have multiple levels, this would be the thing that
you need to throw in every single level, this BP sequence manager, which
again, it's just going to act as that in between that operator between
your sequence player input and events.
All right.
So I'm going to go ahead and just select our sequence to a five start,
which should be in our level and open level sequence.
And now we're going to start building out some of the logic for our sequence.
I'll just kind of move this forward because we have our fade track here.
That's all it is.
You see it fades in and out.
I'm going to move it forward just a little bit.
And you'll notice that in this sequence, we have an events folder already set up.
So again, and keeping consistent with wanting to stay organized.
If you don't have an events folder, right click in this, or you can click
add and we'll do add folder, but our events is already there.
All right.
So now what I need to do is select our BP sequence manager from
the level or your outliner.
I'm going to right click add actor to sequence, add BP sequence manager, drag
this up into our events folder, and now we have it within our sequence.
So now what I'm going to do is under this BP sequence manager, I'm going to
click this plus track and I want to add an event trigger and you'll see here
that it adds the event and there's a we have a new kind of line here for this.
So I'm going to move to four 80 and the question would be, why, well, if I
activate the camera to see the sequence, essentially what we have playing here,
right as our character kind of runs from the screen, runs up to our
platform and then stands here for a second and then eventually we'll run off.
So just before that character runs off screen.
So our frame for 80 is where I want to add a key frame to essentially
handle a let's pause the sequence, wait for the player to input some sort of,
Hey, what do you want to do?
And then continue playing the sequence.
So a four 80 under events, I'm just going to click this little key frame,
kind of move this off and you see now it's created a new key frame for us to do.
So just double click that key frame, which will open up the actual event itself.
Now, if you see this BP sequencer manager event called pause dispatcher,
this is what we're building, but we can go ahead and just delete this.
And there's our BP sequence manager event.
So BP sequence manager event key frame.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag off of this pin and I'm going
to start typing in call and you see, we've got call pause dispatcher.
There we go. And we will just select this up, compile, save, and we are done.
So now we have this set up basically that the sequence will play.
And when it hits this, it's going to fire off an event.
It's going to fire off some type of command to our pause dispatcher that we
have, and then we'll build the rest of the logic in the next section.